in delhi let's go live to that city now
and talk to narendra tenacious
spokesperson for the ruling
bjp party uh good evening thank you for
being with us i mean this is clearly
a humanitarian tragedy uh unfolding here
but
isn't it also a political disaster for
your government
people dying waiting for beds people
dying waiting for oxygen
people dying on mattresses outside
hospitals
and people dying because they have not
been vaccinated that is a
a failure of government isn't it
well there are sure there are challenges
in
some parts of the country is you know
especially in cities like delhi and also
partly in bombay and a few other places
especially when it comes to oxygen
shortage of beds
and also in some cases even shorter
medicines and
as you know health is a state subject
the respective states are handling the
situation
to the best of their capacity and
capabilities and fully assisted by the
in central government in new delhi
like the video you were just showing the
report was from new delhi which as you
know is not ruled by the
by the ruling party but nevertheless is
the national capital
and the central government is trying is
very very level best and
there is some improvement there is no
shortage of oxygen
the area where we are facing a huge
challenge is bringing that oxygen
from plants to the to hospitals and to
those who need it
so but that's being addressed and we are
quite hopeful
that in coming few days this particular
issue would be would be would be
addressed
right well you say it's a state
responsibility uh
but you were very happy to claim success
when um the first wave was dealt with
you passed a resolution saying it can be
said with pride that india defeated
kovid19 and then you said
under the able sensible committed and
visionary leadership
of prime minister modi so if he's if
he's claiming the successes
why doesn't he admit when things go
disastrous
disastrously wrong well first of all the
prime minister didn't claim anything of
that sort
there have been some articles i've seen
the one especially in the london times
but there was a political meeting of the
ruling party our party their
resolution was part was volunteered by
some delegates and some
the delegate decided to go ahead that
was it so it was not just
any kind of resolution on the part of
the central government or the prime
minister office or parliament or
anything of that sort
that was a political meeting where some
enthusiasts they passed a resolution but
as far as the country is concerned we
have been fighting with it
with full force and with tremendous
success in most cases
but this particular you know the second
wave is kind like a tsunami
and as you know tsunami whenever tsunami
happens anywhere in the world
that has of course internal elements our
preparation but
also external elements but so do you
expect
sorry interrupt do you accept that many
of the deaths could have been avoided
if different political decisions had
been taken if you hadn't opened up so
early if you hadn't held
massive rallies in west bengal if you
if you hadn't had a big hindu festival
allowed that to go ahead where millions
gathered
now you see first of all those political
rallies in west bengal that you're
referring mostly those rallies were in
the rural areas
where you know uh pandemic has not been
an issue
and at the same time when it comes to
religious congregations
the moment the government got to know
about it the government appealed and
they immediately decided to call it off
but that was religious government has
absolutely nothing to do with that
particular festival you are referring to
religious one has been going on for the
last seven thousand years
that's decided by the by you know not
during that not during
with respect of course it hasn't it's a
very important festival but not during a
a covid pandemic
well i take your point but at the time
when it was you know
they received the go ahead and they
decided what that time there was no
second wave on the horizon
i mean not only just in the central
government or very state government or
health
authorities or hospitals i mean nobody
could see that on the horizon including
media including bbc
you have got a big big office in new
delhi could they see it no they couldn't
the sky
and delhi they could see it no they
couldn't see it so nobody we couldn't
see it on the horizon it came like a
tsunami
and hit it very hard we accept it but at
the same time now
we are what we are doing is mobilizing
every single possible resort
in order to meet this challenger we are
quite confident you know we will uh
you know meet this challenge and come
out of this defeat kovid and come out of
this uh you know in
pretty good shape okay do you seriously
do you seriously believe that the case
numbers and the death numbers
that are being reported are correct
well right now you see what our focus
is on providing help and medical
assistance to those who need
not really counting the numbers of
course the government is keeping an eye
on that various agencies
but once we are out of all that you know
there's going to be kind of
uh numbers being reported by different
media outlets and all that
but there will be kind of complete
reconciliation so that you know
future preparations can be based on that
but right now the focus
right now the focus is on mobilizing
maximum possible
support for those who need their support
including oxygen okay
okay i understand uh the scientists
there are saying the numbers are
are wrong um one epidemiologist who says
brahma mukherjee he says from all the
modeling we've done we believe the true
number of deaths
is two to five times what is being
reported
well it's quite you see that the same
people did it modeling also one year ago
last april last may
and they said x number of people are
going to lose their life in india and so
and so on that didn't happen
i mean sitting in washington dc at their
lab and doing this number crunching
is their job i respect that but at the
same time you have to see reality on the
ground we are the government we are the
political party we are the people here
we are seeing the situation on the
ground and we are quite you have seen
already the tremendous improvement in
the state of maharashtra
secondly we started from maharashtra you
know and we see the improvement there
the last 10 days and we are pretty
confident
we will see similar improvements in
other parts of the country very soon we
know the country we know our
infrastructure but they can do their
number crunching and you know you can
buy the numbers but
but we we are going more more by the
ground reality here in india and we are
quite
capable of our own you know capabilities
and we have experienced similar
situation in the past
not necessarily covet but other kind of
natural disasters and so on and so forth
so as a country we have tremendous you
know resilience
and we are very confident we will come
out with the support of the people of
india right now our challenge is
to to address and mobilize medical
support those who are busy with the
numbers
i mean very respected but right now our
focus is on how can we save lives
how can we immobilize oxygen i can't we
expend
you know uh our hospitals capacity
number one
so forth mr tenacious we have to leave
it there but it is a
challenge like no other that you faced
recently certainly uh thank you very
much indeed for being with us appreciate
your time